Chris Gethard show you're on public
access okay you're struggling along
you're doing this show where anything
goes where the host kind of has no
control they do things to you yeah you
react naturally yeah and it catches on
people really like it and then you you
move on to cable to fusion and it's
become a real show and I'm curious are
you changing do you want more control
now do you want it to be more
professional do you want it to be locked
down now that it's on I wish it would be
but like the they won't allow it the
people who work on the show they all
came with me from public access and they
don't allow that to happen like we just
shot an episode this week where at one
point I was blindfolded and they
legitimately did not tell me what was
gonna happen and the next thing I knew
there was an actual boa constrictor
around my neck right right and what I
was told was that the director of the
show who's like been with me for years
all the guys in the control room like
the crew guys who aren't my friends they
were all like you have to stop he's
freaking out he's losing his mind is
having a panic attack and he my friend
was in there going no one stopped
anything nothing stops yeah no one
stopped a thing this is good television
yeah so we're not where they're not I'm
still being tormented we just now have
money to spend on snakes right you're
getting a higher degree of danger now
you can pay for a better snake pay for
like a real polar bear to attack you
exactly have you ever been bringing this
this flows from that question ever been
hurt during a show big time
a lot of times the worst one the worst I
ever was hurt was actually we did a live
show at South by Southwest the festival
in Austin is really good time and we did
a thing I'm like really big into like
crowd interaction like face-to-face
interaction so we did a thing called the
human Sunday where I sat in a baby pool
full of ice cream and I was naked and
then at the end of the show everybody in
the crowd was given a spoon and they
could come up and eat from the human
sundae and meet me
and I thought it was gonna be really fun
and I think the crowd had fun with it
but I thought my body heat would melt
the ice cream and instead
I just got frostbite I had like actual
blisters on my arm and a big patch like
the tops of my hands and all around here
was alright let your hands okay alright
yeah yeah you think what you're doing is
can get away from there okay sorry about
that you like a creep on the subway I'm
so sorry I'm sorry so you got frostbite
you have to go to the hospital and say I
got frostbite from ice cream
yeah that's embarrassing it was really
so what audience member and is this just
me that's thinking that she wants to
come up and eat ice cream they all did
touching your nude body they all did it
I was baffled I was baffled yes and now
I'm baffled that just seems wrong and
that one was particularly done because
it wasn't even on TV it was just for
like 80 people you know that was just
for Austin you didn't shoot that no I've
been bad I've been hurt badly hurt but
usually cameras are rolling and then I
don't care then when I wake up at the
hospital I'm like did you get it and
they're like we got it and I'm like
we're all set yeah we didn't even bring
a camera with us